so in the space of advice somebody who's
interested in getting started in machine
learning or reinforcement learning what
advice would you give to maybe an
undergraduate student or maybe even
younger how what are the first steps to
take and further on what are the stapes
steps to take on that journey so
something that I think is important to
do is to is to not be afraid to like
spend time imagining the kind of outcome
that you might like to see so you know
one outcome might be a successful career
a large paycheck or something or
state-of-the-art results on some
benchmark but hopefully that's not the
thing that's like the main driving force
for somebody but I I think that if
someone who's a student considering a
career in AI like takes a little while
sits down and thinks like what do I
really want to see what I want to see a
machine do what I want what do I want to
see a robot do what I want to do and
what I want to see a natural language
system just like imagine you know
imagine it almost like a commercial for
a future product or something or like
like something that you'd like to see in
the world and then actually sit down and
think about the steps that are necessary
to get there and hopefully that thing is
not a better number on imagenet
classification it's like it's probably
like an actual thing that we can't do
today that would be really awesome
whether it's a robot Butler or a you
know a really awesome healthcare
decision making supports us and whatever
it is that you find inspiring and I
think that thinking about that and then
backtracking from there and imagining
the steps needed to get there will
actually do much better research it'll
lead to rethinking the assumptions it'll
lead to working on the bottlenecks other
other people aren't working on
you